on American history TV Sheri Kaplan the
author of petticoats and pinstripes
portraits of women in Wall Street's
history she talks about how women played
an important role in the development of
American Finance she argues that World
War one acted as the watershed moment
for women who entered the financial
world they saw it as part of their
patriotic duty this 30-minute event took
place at the Museum of American Finance
in New York City
good afternoon welcome hi I'm David
Callen president of the Museum of
American Finance we are the only finance
museum in the nation with a core mission
of preserving in the exhibiting and
teaching about our nation's finance and
financial history and we are a
Smithsonian affiliate welcome back
Friends of the museum and welcome back
to our friends from c-span who are
taping today our today is Sheree Kaplan
and she's the author of petticoats and
pinstripes portraits of women in Wall
Street history and well this is Sheree's
first book she is no stranger to writing
you can find her as a contributor to
Forbes calm to Bloomberg law to The
Motley Fool as well as other media
outlets and during her research of this
book we're proud to say that she used
some of the resources here at the museum
including a finding in our collection of
this image for the cover now sherry has
a Wall Street background she was a vice
president and assistant general counsel
at Goldman Sachs he is also on the
securities arbitration roster of FINRA
the Financial Industry Regulatory
Authority her undergraduate work was at
Yale her JD was at the University of
Virginia where she got her law degree
and if you go to Sherry kaplan.com which
is her website you'll see that
inspiration for her writing often comes
from a nice cup of tea that's by her
side are a piece of chocolate and so to
provide Sherri with inspiration today we
present her from the museum shop a
Hershey's bar and we look forward now to
your speech welcome to the Museum of
American Finance Shari
thanks
[Applause]
thank you all for coming on this
beautiful day and thank you to the
museum for hosting this event I put
together a PowerPoint on the topic and
we're going to start with that and then
afterwards they'd be happy to take any
questions come here we go in a word Wall
Street is not the place for a lady to
find fortune or character that's what
noted American Banker Henry clewd said
today in 1908 about the idea of women on
Wall Street any thoughts about that well
what are we talking about when we talk
about the subject of women and Wall
Street and why does it matter I wrote
this book because I wanted to read it
and it did not exist when I first wanted
to know more about the topic several
years ago I look for a book about it on
the library shelves
I found the books on Wall Street history
that I had already read these were
excellent histories but they contain
very few references to the woman's
experience I found a book on the
african-american experience I found a
book on the Jewish American experience I
found books that interviewed women who
worked on Wall Street in the 1980s and
the 1990s but I could not find anything
on the broader topic on the topic of the
evolution of women's roles in American
finance so after being unable to find
someone else's account I went searching
for the answers myself and I found
myself asking these questions what is
Wall Street where are the women and why
do we care so let's backtrack a bit and
get a quick review of Wall Street's
development
1792 marked the formal beginnings of
what would later become a New York Stock
Exchange in 1792 24 men stood beneath a
Buttonwood tree and lower Manhattan and
I signed an agreement that established a
new market for a more orderly system of
selling and buying securities later the
invention of the Telegraph in 1844 the
rides of industrialization and civil war
spending lavished Richards on Wall
Street and gave way to the Gilded Age
the term Wall Street had now become
symbolic of the nation's securities
market by 1918 world where one had
catapulted Wall Street into the
epicenter of global finance and a
twentieth century then witnessed great
market runs and bubbles at both
financial innovation and regulation took
hold the investor base expanded as did
the array of new products now Wall
Street did not connote just an address
and lower Manhattan but the vast
financial world that is interconnected
through technology and geographic bounds
no longer mattered so where were the
women they were not beneath the
Buttonwood tree
most people here tend to think that
Muriel Siebert was the first woman to
take up a professional path on Wall
Street when she purchased her seat on
the New York Stock Exchange in 1967 but
she was hardly the first woman to make
her mark in American Finance two other
names that most frequently serviced
are there - Victoria Woodhull and Hedy
Greene Woodhull also the first woman to
run for US president and her sister
Tennessee Claflin had made the
acquaintance of Commodore Vanderbilt the
sisters were looking to get rich and
Woodhull wanted to fund her political
aspirations they opened the first female
owned brokerage in 1870 the firm lasted
only a few years and they were largely
dismissed as a
joke to be sure they were more keen on
courting publicity than on analyzing
earnings but they were certainly savvy
marketers and they courted publicity so
well that went enlighten them to many of
their modern-day cohorts in the
brokerage industry heady green is
usually dismissed at the miserly
eccentric dubbed the witch of Wall
Street and certainly her fashion choice
did not do nothing to help her shed that
image she was a wealthy heiress who
vastly increased her fortune through
shrewd investments her unfortunate
nickname though overlooked her keen
financial mind and her participation in
key events of the time from a broader
perspective the business dealings of
these women helped not only draw the
attention of other women to finance but
to raise the public scrutiny of whether
a woman belonged on Wall Street at all
another woman of that same era goes for
the most part little-noticed
does anyone recognize this person that
is Maggie Walker of Richmond Virginia
she recognized the importance of
financial literacy and empowerment
particularly for black women and she
found at the st. Luke penny Savings Bank
in 1903 her legacy was not based in
Manhattan and it was not primarily in
securities but it indoors to a much
greater extent than her better known
counterparts the entity that she found
it lasted into the 21st century at the
country's longest continually owned and
operated african-american bank there are
also women who ventured into the
financial mattered even before these
Gilded Age leaders some of these women
were well-known Abigail Adams and Sarah
Livingston J come to mind
they both actively invested in
government securities and Bank shares
and there were scores of others who also
invested and who remain unnamed and
unknowns
the most part for instance between 1759
and 1760 61% of the investors in the
Pennsylvania Indian comission loan were
women and between 1792 and 1799 11 % of
stockholders of the insurance company of
North America were female
so women may not have stood beneath the
Buttonwood tree in 1792 but some were
participating in the formation of the
capital structure of the emerging
country and they had been taking part in
the colonial economy before then despite
legal restrictions many women who were
single or widowed engaged in commerce as
she merchants or deputy husbands from
the 1600s on personal necessity and
patriotic duty gave rise to women taking
a more active role in managing financial
matters women helped raise funds for the
Continental Army and they took care of
their families farms and businesses
while their husbands were fighting in
the war these responsibilities raised
their confidence it broadened their
ability and it gave them a sense of
empowerment even if it was short-lived
for as the country entered the 19th
century a woman's place was still seen
as being at home World War one provided
the watershed moment by which more women
were introduced to financed again
personal necessity and patriotic duty
coincided to make this happen in this
case it was the women who powered the
Liberty Bonds sales during World War one
who deserve the credit
they galvanized public attention on the
skills and prowess of women and they
brought in the financial vocabulary of
the volunteers and the public at large
soon many of the women who had once
powered bond drives were among the first
to enter the expanding commercial
banking workforce and we tend to think
of networking as a modern-day
development but in fact the first
professional organizations for women in
finance originated in 1921 with the
beginnings of the association of bank
women and the formation of the women's
bond club according to rumor a woman
even sought membership on the New York
Stock Exchange in 1927 40 years before
that actually became a reality women
made inroads particularly in commercial
banking during the interwar years
Isabelle Benham became the first female
railroad analyst in 1934 and embarked on
a successful career that spanned six
decades Mary Roebling became the first
woman president of a commercial bank
Trenton Trust in 1937 when world war ii
came again a familiar story women
answered the country's call to duty and
even filled empty posts on Wall Street
but they were booted out when peacetime
prevailed and the men came home but in
the coming decade both a booming economy
and broadening acceptance of women's
roles helped power further progress from
the 1950s through the 1970s both Wall
Street and American women staked their
positions amid a changing landscape a
few intrepid leaders broke new ground at
the crossroad a particular note Mary
Roebling became the first woman governor
of the American Stock Exchange in 1956
and in 1965 Julia Montgomery Walsh and
Phillips Peterson became the first women
members there the field of securities
analysis grew and so too did
well fund assets being vigil in dividual
investor was attaining greater
significance the investor base became
increasingly democratized and by the
late 1960s the waspish preserve of Wall
Street itself began to fade many firsts
were achieved by women and financed
during these years they pursued their
careers against a backdrop of the
women's liberation movement and other
calls for societal change by the 1980
women had come a long way in finance but
obstacles remained they were not going
to go further on Wall Street if the
financial sector could not cure its own
ills
Wall Street was plagued by problems
caused by playing technological catch-up
in the late 1970s and emerging from
stagflation not helping women either
with a bit of anti-feminist backlash and
a sense of complacency as the Equal
Rights Amendment was defeated in 1982
and the wage gap also increased once the
economy boomed again Wall Street gained
a sort of pop culture fascination and
for the first time women numbered among
it stars
Elaine Garza relly who predicted the
1987 market crash an Abbe Joseph Cohen
who at the mused of the 1990s bull
market became how told names other women
however faced inhospitable workplaces
beginning in 1996 the first gender-based
class-action lawsuits were brought
against major Wall Street firms at
present we see more and more women
successfully forging strong identities
within high-profile careers but women
remain among the first to go both at
general and at higher levels
today overtly hostile workplaces no
longer survive both men and women are
speaking out about the need to create a
flourishing pipeline of women coming
into and succeeding in finance calls for
greater workplace flexibility and
financial education are also important
for both genders the book delved into
these themes and a broad array of three
centuries of social and financial
history like a survey and it's meant to
be easily readable for both those
familiar with Wall Street and those left
though the book celebrates overlooked
legacies of female accomplishments and
finance and sets them in the context of
their time two appendices provide handy
tools for quick reference to significant
women and to a chronology of milestones
go back to the question of whether the
presence of women on Wall Street matters
remember this guy wonder what he would
think about what christine lagarde the
first female head of the International
Monetary Fund would have to say on the
topic of women in Wall Street
approximately 100 years later in a 2012
interview with Niall Ferguson she
quipped that the degree of tragedy
stemming from the 2008 financial crisis
might not have happened had Lehman
Brothers been a bit more Lehman sisters
and brothers what do you think that ends
my formal presentation and I'd now like
to throw the floor open to any questions
and a microphone can be passed around or
if anyone has broader topics on this
topic of women in Wall Street and how
they fit in and can survive
it agreed and her involvement in the
panic of 1907 yes
petit Green is a fascinating character
and I mean I would love to have lunch
with her but you know if that happened
she probably wouldn't have offered me
any seat food of her own although she
was so wealthy in 1907 the financial
world was in crisis mode and JP Morgan
gathered a group of the leading
businessmen into his office late at
night and had a green although she
didn't acknowledge it formally was
thought to have been spotted in there at
the New York Times article that sort of
described her appearance coming down the
steps from that meeting that night so
it's basically agreed that she was
involved in this meeting that helped
stave off the 1907 financial panic and
they were trying to think of ways to
keep the liquidity going while they
sorted things out and more banks do not
fail Hetty Greene you know was very g
engaged in the corporate matters of the
day that involved a lot of railroad
mergers and transactions and she did not
quiver and Shake and try to hide the
fact that she was actively investing in
she would the woman she was doing it and
she was giving out her opinions while
doing so
being a trader on Wall Street is
particularly challenging shift in women
as traders since open outcry auctions
have faded an electronic trading has
replaced it I think that's a great
question and I would think yes because
certainly in the physical arena of
trading of females more diminutive
stature in general it's not going to
serve her well in an open pit open
outcry kind of system so I do think that
the rise of electronic trading and
platforms levels the platform more for
for women to participate more fully but
that's not the only obstacle you know
they're still you know you have to make
sure that women want to get into that
kind of role and that once there they do
have people who support their careers as
well could you talk a bit about books
Lee born and watching the changes that
she had wanted to have in the CS City
what what could are these reforms going
through now them and would they have
made it what difference might they have
made in 2008 well I will say that in
this really goes a little bit outside
the scope of my book that more talked
about the history of women on Wall
Street leading up to 2000 but I do note
that in the aftermath of the 2008 crisis
many of the leading regulators federal
regulators were female and that they
were very proactive and Brooksley born
even before then was always very
involved in federal regulation of the
markets something to note that I don't
think was ever largely spread around in
the general press was a part of the dog
Wall Street Reform Act there is a
provision that calls for more
recognition of diversity in Wall three
in the financial sector and how
government contract is engaged with the
financial marketplace
and there's offices and regulations that
were provided for in the regulation to
talk about and try to raise the level of
diversity on Wall Street including for
women as far as I know we've yet to see
how they're really put into practice and
what will come of that quickly who's the
woman on the cover of your book well I
think the Museum of American Finance can
answer that better than I could it's
actually an ad in old tobacco
advertising card so I don't know her
name to me she's anonymous and that's
why I loved her on the cover because she
sort of represents just a woman as
opposed to a woman that you might know
and here she is loving to read the stock
ticker and looking pretty happy about it
so I don't know her exact name I don't
know if you have more of the backstory
on that but I love that because as I
said there were women who were
participating in finance all along
during all the heirs of our financial
history there's one one more question on
the ruling lady well she related to the
MU huling who built the Brooklyn Bridge
of the Roebling Lee yes she had married
into the Roebling family and her story
is very interesting because she didn't
embark on a career of Finance it's
within the 1950s and her husband was of
that family and they had created the
Trenton Trust and her husband died
prematurely and all the sudden she was
thrust into the leadership I mean she
could have backed away and said no thank
you I want to just do the country club
scene but her relatives and everyone
said you know you have got common sense
you can do this and she did it and her
legacy is remarkable because she did it
in the kind of a 1952 context while
breaking new ground she was known for
always looking very ladylike and she
loved the social aspects that went along
with being a leading community in the
Newark era but again she was the first
female head of a major commercial bank
and then became the first woman governor
of the Amer
and Stock Exchange so I found her career
it's kind of a paradigm of that era 1950
like the Brooklyn Bridge bridging
different spans if you will the 1950
context of a woman belongs at home
versus coming changes of getting more
involved into the corporate world okay
that's about it I thank everybody and
I'll be available if anyone has anything
else that they'd like to bring up thank
you
[Applause]